yeah i'm curious uh because like i said
earlier about like people
loving japan now what do you think about
people who like like think of japan as a
utopia
like this kind of perfect society
because people give me [ __ ]
when i say like bad things about japan
like if you don't like it just leave and
i'm like no no i'm just british i just
complain about everything
yeah sometimes i find it very
interesting like uh
like what is so great you know it's not
that japan has changed so much recently
it's just that
suddenly it's become a utopia so yeah um
i just think that japan is very unique
in even in asia like and there are a lot
of things that japan does
originally like you know anime and
j-rock and j-pop
and all these uh culture things that
japan originally did
that is now um widespread in the world
so
um it's not that japan has changed or
anything it's just that um
those little things are being noticed
again i guess it's just like it's also
just like the more like it's more
exposure to like over glorification
because because now we know that japan
does all of these like unique things
that are very different to western
countries
it's suddenly better quite unquote yeah
you know like yeah of course like there
are a lot of things about japan that are
just
i don't know what is so i mean i i love
matcha but i don't
know what is so like heavenly about
matcha
do you like matcha i i do but i do i
understand that it's good but i don't
know why in america
in america especially they treat matcha
like a brand of cocaine
japan does too japan has matcha
everything i'm pretty sure there's like
matcha toilet roll that you can eat no
no but but no but what i'm saying is
that in america there are so many things
in america like so many like even if
you're in japan even if it's a
hint of asian they're just like yeah
we're gonna have much of something
no there's no no i mean there is of
course there is more
in japan but it's like like the what's
up with the the way the
is like um marked it towards like the
americans it's like this exotic thing
it's a unique taste because matcha is
like an official
frappuccino taste yeah is it yeah like
around the world
yeah around the world oh i didn't i
didn't know that yeah yeah because you
don't get frappuccinos gone i'm the only
one out of the three of us don't
get a frappuccino because you've turned
more white since you've moved to japan
what it is gone it is one of those okay
i just think
that globally the world likes green
stuff like
wasabi it's green it's green
so if it's green it's probably green i
love that i love that
is that just is that what it comes down
to that's the only reason that i can
come up with
green tea i mean i mean that's kind of
just much reason that's all matcha is
it's just tea
it's just green it's just green honestly
i i'm honestly i think marcia slaps and
i'll i'll be the one in the corner who
will defend matcha don't get me wrong
i like matcha
somewhere i belong oh no
so much is just like it's about the
iceberg but there are so many things
about japan are
being discovered and are being like
utopia eyes so
like bidets should be yeah no yeah
exactly there are so there are a lot of
things about japan and japanese culture
that i think rightfully so should be put
up on a pedestal like
bidets for example right like i mean
[ __ ] you experience a bidet your life
has basically changed for the better
as we discussed in an earlier heated
toilet seats
japan has normalized heated toilet seats
great things about japan that you
find really like amazing i would like to
know about it okay for me
personally coming from sydney uh sydney
has one of the worst [ __ ] public
transport systems in the world
like it's i've discussed it in a podcast
before but like
just having coming to japan and being
like
okay the tr the schedule says the
train's coming at
exactly 257 and the fact that i can go
to the platform at 256
and the train arrives exactly one minute
later is like
if if it came on time in australia you'd
think something was wrong
you'd think the bus driver had like a
gun to his head being like arrive here
on time because otherwise just never
comes on time
yeah i the there's there's two sides of
japan for me because i
love the convenience of japan but
there's two there's two sides of the
convenience because there's one
there's the daily living because just
living in japan
just the daily side daily living side of
japan it's so convenient it's so easy
and then there's the business side of
japan which is like the exact
opposite of convenience so i but like
just living here
i i feel like i get the best the best of
the best of japan because i'm
self-employed so it's way more
convenient just to live here
it drives me insane that put like how
intensely they'll pursue
politeness here like to a point where it
makes everyone's life inconvenient like
it's gone saying about business they'll
they'll keep the people in the chain and
of the business that shouldn't be in the
chain
they'll be middlemen in everything just
out of like courtesy
and there's a point where i'm just like
come on this is ridiculous like
we can talk to about ourselves like no
no you have to go through the five
middleman
who introduced them do i really need to
get approval from the boss's boss to
just
go get some lunch yeah i just i just
want to go yeah i mean
but i mean the things i love uh i like
the safety
you know yeah yeah living in london it's
kind of sketch at times
speaking of schedules we've got to talk
about america right like oh right right
yeah new york to tokyo has been like
yeah
world apart and also you know being from
the uk not known for our
culinary action excellence um so it's
nice having food that tastes good all
the time
at a reasonable price i'm scared because
you know i i was very good at eating
just like potato being like oh this is
amazing isn't it just a potato exactly
when you come to japan
you become really like gourmet
you expect everything to taste good and
you're like
yeah to me pizza was anything with
cheese bread and tomato and i was pretty
happy with that yeah yeah
with butter cheese on it is good and
then yeah now it's like is this
this is stone baked right oh no oh no
this is the locally grown it's locally
grown yeah yeah which prefecture are
these
uh strawberries from oh really that
prefecture oh no no no no no it happened
taking order didn't cost a thousand
dollars for one strawberry get that out
of here
every time i go back to the uk now i the
hardest thing i have to adjust to is
just going to like
go go through like my ubereats or the
local restaurant guide
like to my area and just seeing nothing
that's appealing to me
unless i travel all the way up to london
in the city center is really good here
yeah take out in the uk it's like which
greasy food do you want
yeah it's like you get a choice between
kebab kebab pizza
chicken burgers and that's i like
chicken
i mean there's like i like chicken
burgers as well but there's a time and a
place for chicken burgers what about you
what's it what's the best thing what's
the best thing of both
like what do you like most about america
what do you like most about japan um
well you know the thing that i i liked
about america was that it's really
diverse
you know you could go anywhere and
really just
feel at home yeah
yeah it's very open but in japan you
know it's hard to
get friendly with people i think it
takes time people are more
sort of shy and have that one wall yeah
you feel like you have to break down
multiple
barriers to like really get to know
someone and even then
it's it's quite hard to be able to call
someone a friend yeah yeah yeah
so that's one of the differences i feel
but
there are a lot of things i love about
japan as well you you feel safe you know
you can trust everyone most
most of the time yeah yeah you can trust
you know
and the quality is always you know very
high for anything not just food but for
any kind of service or you know
it's great but i think that uh you're sp
you get spoiled in japan so when once
you start living in japan for a while
and you go overseas like everything
feels
slow everything feels you know like not
rude i almost understand why some people
just don't travel outside of japan i'm
like why would you
like what are you gonna do things just
work here yeah and that's what i love
about japan it's just
everything you didn't think about works
and then except for business the
business side but just like i said
everything
outside of that just perfectly works
realize the london underground was i
mean i knew it was dirty i didn't
realize it was that dirty
until you go like that i knew that i
knew that
you get like the you know you get the
railway to the airport in japan it's
ultra clean
you get in your plane you get home you
have to get the underground to go home
you're like oh god there's
[ __ ] everywhere well i mean you're from
new york right like new york city
it's just like another level i i you
know i normally feel safe on
public transport but the underground the
subway in new york really tested
my ability to feel safe yeah but even in
the
music industry like concert wise i
realized there was a huge difference
like when i went to
um san jose to do my first concert like
you know it was american
style concert so yeah um we were already
used to doing the japanese style and
then we went to the
the venue and then it was lunch time so
um in japan you know even if it's
lunchtime if there's a lot of work done
or you know
no one just strays off you know goes
yeah
lunch break or anything and everyone
like if you have an hour that means you
have about 30 minutes right right after
like cleanup and everything but yeah
back in the states um it was twelve
o'clock everyone disappeared
and then no one was there so the
japanese team was there uh waiting to
you know
it was like oh what do we do and then
we're okay so
lunch break is one hour so at one
o'clock we come back and we do
rehearsals again
so we were we were planning on that but
then like the camera people and the
lighting people like didn't appear
for another hour or so that sounds like
an american colony
but the amazing thing is even though
they don't like you know do all that
preparation stuff yeah like the the show
boom they they do their thing they do
their thing they don't need rehearsal
they just um they do their thing god
damn that's i i
if most conventions i've been to they've
been like technical difficulties on like
every
every panel that i've posted a technical
difficulty
that's that's you know you know that's
how the world works and japan is just
very you know perfectionism and
they're just like a little too over
cautious at times where it's like why
are you stressing out about this
like you don't have to have 17
rehearsals like
exactly one or two is enough